work continues on corinthians arena and
time is nearly up in just a few days the
biggest football tournament in the world
will kick off here against this chaotic
backdrop comes a candid admission from
the mayor of Rio de Janeiro who says in
retrospect staging the football world
cup across 12 cities was not a good idea
I think we did it say we should have a
fewer cities a whole super world cup
there what we have and that brought this
kind of situation with potentially for
stadiums surplus to requirements Brazil
could have saved billions of dollars the
observation isn't lost on the locals
teachers have joined a growing list of
workers who have been staging industrial
action furious at the vast amounts of
money spent on football that could have
gone to schools and hospitals and it's
not just the stadiums that aren't ready
roads pavements and areas for media and
sponsors are still incomplete Rio's
mayor admits it's a bad look until now I
mean I think there was a huge damage you
know to reputation when we don't have
everything ready by time all time that
is a bit difficult we need to do it very
well and I'm sure we have good Brazil's
not the first country to suffer protests
or get behind schedule when staging a
major event once the football itself
gets underway this hope the excitement
will overshadow the problems and perhaps
the experience will help Rio get it
right when it hosts the Olympics in two
years time by the way the IOC last month
called those preparations the worst that
ever seen more lallan Bloomberg